[موسيقى]
هنا الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نص صهيب شرايير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
في اوكرانيا بعد المسيارات حرب دبابات كيف
تنتقل من الدفاع الى الهجوم وتطلب مدرعات
من برج ايفال رساله تضامن فرنسيه مع
المحتاجين في ايران وامريكيو المسجون في
طهران يبدا واضرابا عن الطعام
جريمه غامضه في كابول وروايتان ناشطه
افغانيه تقتل وابتهامات لطالبان بالوقوف
وراء الحادثه
بعد ان اختفى لثلاثين عاما ايطاليا تعتقل
اخطر زعماء المافيا والمطلوب رقم واحد
[موسيقى]
يقال ان افضل طريقه للدفاع هي الهجوم
ويبدو بانه اوكرانيا وحلفاءها باتو يتبعون
هذه المقوله في الحرب مع روسيا فمن الواضح
ان خطه اوكرانيا في الحرب قد تغيرت بشكل
تدريجي منذ بدايه العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه قبل اقل من عام فبينما كان الجيش
الاوكراني يعتمد بشكل كبير على خطط دفاعيا
مع الاكتفاء باطلاق مسيرات لمهاجمه
العناصر الروسيه تغيرت قواعد اللعبه وباتت
اوكرانيه تبادل الى الهجوم وهو ما مكانها
من استعاده السيطره على العديد من المناطق
ابرزها مدينه خسر
اكيد ايضا ان الاشهر العشره الماضيه كانت
فرصه للخبراء العسكريين الحلفاء اوكرانيا
الاستخلاص الدروسي والعبر بخصوص الخطط
والاسلحه المستخدمه في هذه الحرب بهذا
الخصوص قالت شبكه سينان ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا مكنه الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
الغربيين من دراسه اداء وفاعليه اسلحتها
وانظمتها التي قدمتها الى كياف ووفقا
لضابط عمليات الامريكيه المطلع كود شبكتي
امان ان بعض الانظمه التي قدمتها واشنطن
لكييف مثل الطائره من دون طيار اظهرت اداء
اقل من المتوقع على ارض المعركه واوضحت
الشبكه ان العديد من الحكومات الغربيه
استجابت على ضوء ذلك لدعوات الرئيس لينسكي
لتزويد اكياف بالدبابات في القتاليه بعد
تقييم واسع النطاق بشان متطلبات الحرب
وزير الدفاع البريطاني بعنوان كشف عن حزمه
دعم العسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا قائلا بين
هذه المساعدات هي رد محسوب على العدوان
الروسي المتزايد والقذف العشوائي
بعد انظمه صواريخ بعيده المدى ومدرعات
وانظمه دفاع جوي ارضي دبابات تشارجر اثنين
البريطانيه الصنع في طريقها الى القوات
الاوكرانيه في احدث دعم عسكري لكاف للتصدي
للعمليات العسكريه الروسيه المستمره هذا
ما اعلنه رئيس الوزراء البريطانيك واكده
وزير دفاعه للنواب
الاعلان عن اهم حزمه من القوه القتاليه
حتى الان لتسريع النجاح الاوكراني تشمل
سربا من دبابات تشالنجر اثنين بالمركبات
الاسترداد واصلاح المدرعات وسوف نتبرع
بسلاح المدفعين مضره لاوكرانيا مجهز بثمان
بنادق عاليه الدقه واسلحه المدفعيه اخرى
في مراحل مختلفه من الجاهليه
هذه الحزمه العسكريه الجديده من بريطانيا
الى اوكرانيا حظيت بتاييد واسع من مختلف
الاحزاب السياسيه للوقوف في وجه الرئيس
بوتن الذي اخطا في تقدير حملته العسكريه
ولوقوف الدول الغربيه في صف واحد بجانب
الرئيس الاوكراني لحمايه اراضي بلاده كما
تقول لندن تعمل كيف ان يمهد القرار
البريطاني ارسال الحلفاء اسلحه ومعدات
عسكريه ثقيله متطوره للقوات الاوكرانيه
كانت قبل اشهر فقط من المحرمات لتفادي
تصعيدي روسيا الحرب
اوكرانيا اقنعت حلفائها البريطانيين
والفرنسيين والبولنديين تدريجيا لارسال
اسلحه النوعيه تحدث فارقا على ارض
الاقتتال ما سيزيد الضغط على برلين لتسليم
الدبابات قتاليه حديثه من نوع لابد اثنين
الى استخدام دباباتها يجب ان تكون في
اوكرانيا للقتال على الارض وينطبق الشيء
نفسه على كل دوله لا تزال تمتلك اسلحه في
المخازن ولا تمنحها لاوكرانيا واحد اكبر
التهديدات للامن في العالم هو روسيا
والبلد الوحيد القادر على ايقاف روسيا هو
اوكرانيا
بريطانيا التي تعتبر ثانيه اكبر المانحين
لاوكرانيا بعد الولايات المتحده سيحث رئيس
وزراءها ريس هناك الشركاء الغربيين على
تسريع الدعم لاوكرانيا مع اقتراب مرور عام
على الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وروسيا في
موقف ضعيف في ساحه المعركه بسبب مشاكل
الامداد وتدهور روحي معنويه جنودها
مصطفى زارو العربيه
بشكل كبير مشدده على انواع محدده من بينها
دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه والتي تتميز
بقدرات عاليه لنتعرف على بعض قدرات هذه
الدبابه ابرامز مشاهدينا هي دبابه
القتاليه امريكيه دخلت الخدمه عام 80 وهي
من النوع الثقيل حيث تزن اكثر من سبعين
طولنا ولا تتجاوزوا اقصى سرعه لها 48 كلم
في الساعه يبلغ طولها حوالي 10 امتار وهي
مصممه لحرب المدرعه الحديث همم حيث جهزت
بمدفع رئيسي من عيار 120 م كما انها تتوفر
على نظام وقايه من الاسلحه المدره فضلا عن
نظام الاعتراضي المقذوفات
امدادات والدبابات اثارت حفيظه الكرملين
في موسكو الذي حذر من ان الدبابات التي
تخطط بريطانيا لارسالها الى اوكرانيا
ستحترق محذرا الغربه من ان امداد اوكرانيا
باسلحه اكثر تطورا لن يغير نتيجه الحرب
هذا هو وصلت معدات عسكريه امريكيه الى
الدنمارك بهدف اجراء تدريبات عسكريه على
الجناح الشرقي لحيث شمال الاطلسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ناديه البيبيسي معنا مباشره من واشنطن
نادي اهلا بك معنا هل سيحصل الاوكرانيون
على المزيد من الدبابات الامريكيه
اهلا بك سهيب اعتقد بان هذه الاداره اعلنت
منذ اليوم الاول بانها ملتزمه عسكريه
بتقديم كل الدعم الاوكرانيا وبالتالي اذا
طلب الرئيس الينسكي دبابات ابرامز او
صواريخ باتريت او همم هاي مارز او غيرها
هذه الاداره مستعده لان تقدم كل ما يحتاجه
او يحتاجه الجيش الاوكراني للدفاع عن
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عدا عن ذلك الجنرال
ميل وهو رئيس هيئه الاركان يشرف على
تدريبات لحوالي 500 جندي اوكراني في
المانيا وطبعا يريد ان يكون هناك جهزيه
خلال خمس الى ثمانيه اسابيع وبالتالي هذه
الاداره بالرغم انه هناك علامات استفهام
في الكونجرس بانه لا يمكن ان يكون هناك شك
على بياض بالنسبه للمساعدات العسكريه الا
انها ترى بانها هذه الحرب هي حرب للدفاع
عن الديمقراطيات الغربيه وبالتالي واشنطن
ملتزمه بتقديمها تحتاجه كيف طوال هذه
الفتره ال ال الحقيقيه ايضا مستقبل هذا
الدعم ليس فقط امريكي يبدو اكبر المساله
تبدو اكبر من مساله الدبابات الامريكيه
فقط او التسييح الامريكي هناك دعم بالفعل
بدا يصل من بريطانيا ومن فرنسا مثلا من
حلف شمال الاطلسي همم وهو ما يثير حفيظه
الكريم لان في موسكو لماذا يغير الحلفاء
سياسه الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا هل هو تحول
في مسار الحرب
اكيد هو تحول لانه الاداره الامريكيه تقول
بان مطامع روسيا تتجاوز حتى اوكرانيا وبان
كل اوروبا الشرقيه مهدده وبالتالي هي ترى
بان الرئيس بوتن لن يتراجع عن هذه
العمليات العسكريه التي اصبحت حرب متاجر
وهو يحاول الان كما تقول واشنطن ان يقوم
بهجوم كبير جدا ومن هنا تحس اداره الرئيس
كل الحلفاء وخصوصا في حلف شمال الاطلسي
على تقديم المساعدات وهي ترى بانه طبعا
بريطانيا دوله حنيفه وقريبه من وجهه نظر
الامريكيه همم ان تقوم بتقديم هذه
الدبابات هو امر يعني يثلج الصدر هذه
الاداره وتريد بالفعل ان يكون هناك التزام
ليس فقط من واشنطن لكن من دول النيته
بالتحديد والدول القريبه من اوكرانيا
بتقديم كل انواع الدعم سواء كانت طائرات
كما راينا الاعفاء الدبابات كما ان اليوم
همم من بريطانيا او حتى التدريب الجنود
لكن الطلب بتاعه من رئيس لينسكي هو الدفاع
الجوي تقديم طبعا طائرات يمكن ان تسد
الصواريخ الروسيه حتى الان الاداره كانت
متردده لانها لا تريد ان تتسع رقه هذه
الحرب لتكون مواجهه بين موسكو وبين واشنطن
بدل من عندكم بينك وبين موسكو
شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
وبعد تعهد كل من فرنسا وبولندا والمملكه
المتحده بارسال دبابات للجيش الاوكراني
يبدو ان معركه دبابات تلوح في الافق بين
الجانبين في سيناري يذكرون ربما بمعركه
كورس او معركه الدبابات التي وقعت قبل
نحوي 80 عاما وحددت بشكل كبير لصار الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
معركه كورسكا
[موسيقى]
سميت نسبه الى مكان حدوثها وهو مدينه
كورسكس سوريتيه تعتبر اكبر معركه دبابات
في التاريخ
والعشرين من اغسطس
تواجهت خلالها قوه المانيا والقوه السوفيه
من اصولهم من الدبابات المانيا شاركت ب
1920 دبابه في مشاركه الاتحاد السوفيتي
بخمسه الاف ومئه دبابه
انتهت المعركه بانتصار الاستراتيجي
لسوفيات مكانهم من مواصله الزحف نحو برلين
[موسيقى]
دعت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
خاصه لمتابعه القاده الروس على خلفيه
الحرب في اوكرانيا خلال مداخله لها في مقر
محكمه العدل الدوليه في لاهاي الى انشائي
محكمه من اجل تقديم القاده الروسي الى
العداله وقد تكون مستنده الى القانون
الاوكراني لكن مقرها في الخارج وتضم قضاه
دوليه وقالت نحتاج الى توصيل رساله واضحه
الى القياده الروسيه هنا والان افادها ان
الحرب العدوانيه لن تمر دون عقاب
اعلن المستشار والالماني استقاله وزيره
الدفاع كريستين للامبيرخت وقدم لها الشكر
على التزامها الهائل واعلن انه سيتم تعيين
خليفه لها قريبا
انها لا ترغب في مواصلات مهمتها لقد عملت
وبكل سرور مع كريستين لمريخ لسنوات عديده
الان ايضا بعد الحرب العدوانيه الروسيه
الرهيبه على اوكرانيا اظهرت وزيره الدفاع
التزاما هائلا بضمان ترك المسار الانهزامي
الذي سلكناه لعقود ولكي نحقق اختراقها
كبيرا مهما لدفاع عن الوطن ولكن ايضا لدعم
اوكرانيا على وجه التحديد
[موسيقى]
عرضت على برج ايفال في باريس كلمات
متضامنيه مع الاحتجاجات في ايران وابي ذكر
مروري اربعه اشهر على مقتل الشابه
الايرانيه على ايدي قوه الامن وكتب على
برج ايفل كلمات امراه حياه حريه ووسم اوقف
الاعدام في ايران وذكرت بلديته باريس في
بيان ان الخطوه تاتي تحيه لاولئك الذين
يقاتلون بشجاعه من اجل حريتهم بينما يستمر
النظام الايراني في اعدام المحتاجين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نظم العشرات امام البرلماني الاوروبي في
مدينه ستراسبورغ الفرنسيه تظاهرات للضغط
على الحكومات الاوروبيه والاتحاد الاوروبي
بادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني كم منظمه
ارهابيه وكانت وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
قالت في وقت سابق انها تعمل مع شركائها
الاوروبيين على فرض عقوبات جديده على
ايران بسبب قمع الاحتجاجات المستمره في ما
لم تستبعد فكره تصنيف الحرس الثوري كم
منظمه الارهابيه فيما وصفت المانيا هذه
الخطوه بالمهمه والمنطقيه السياسيه
ننظم الجاريه الايرانيه هنا في مدينه
ستراسبورغ شرقيه فرنسا تظاهره ضخمه
بالتحديد هنا امام مقر البرلمان الاوروبي
وذلك للمطالبه بادراج الحرس الثوري
الايراني على لائحه المنظمات الارهابيه
للاتحاد الاوروبي ويشارك في هذا التحرك
متظاهرون من حوالي 50 مدينه اوروبيه توقيت
هذه التظاهره ايضا يتزامن مع اجتماعا
للبرلمان الاوروبي للبحث في سبل فرض
عقوبات جديده على ايران بعد الاعدامات
الاخيره وسيحضره ايضا مفوض السياسه
الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف
المتظاهرون اطلقوا هتافات مؤيده
للاحتجاجات في ايران
ضد الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران وكذلك
حملوا رسائل موجهه الى البرلمانيين
الاوروبيين كتب عليها كونوا صوتنا وماذا
تنتظرون بعد لاضافه الحارس الثوري
الايراني على لائحه المنظمات الارهابيه
هذه التظاهره لن تكون الاخيره لكن
المتظاهرين هنا يعولون على
والضغط الذي تشكله على القاده الاوروبيين
لمنع نصب المزيد من المشانق في ايران فادي
دهوك العربيه ستراسبورغ
[موسيقى]
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه
استدعاءات سفير الايراني للمره الثانيه
خلال اسبوع بسبب عمليات الاعدام التي
تنفذها بلاده واوضح متحدث باسم الخارجيه
الالمانيه ان الخطوه جاءت بسبب ما خوف في
برلين بشان سجل طهران في مجال حقوق
الانسان من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشيناك ان وزير
الخارجيه جيمس كليفر يتحدث امام البرلمان
بشان اعدام السلطات الايرانيه للمواطن
البريطانيه الايراني علي اكبر
من جانب الاخر قال وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه جيمس كليفر لان النظام
الايراني قام بتعذيب علي اكبر بعد ان شرح
له الاخير ما تعرض له قبل وفاته مشيرا الى
ان اكبر كان ضحيه الانتقام السياسي
قبل موته شرح السيد اكبري ما حدث له
والتعذيب الذي تعرض له بدون شك لقد كان
ضحيه للانتقام السياسي لنظام
الوحشيلا لقياده لا تتورع عن استخدام اداه
سياسيه لاسكات الانتقادات وتصفيه الحسابات
وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه اكمل حديثه
قائلا ايضا ان بريطانيا تقف الى جانب
الشعب الايراني الذي يطالب بحقوقه وحريته
امام سياسه القمع الوحشي التي يتخذها
النظام الملك
اعدام السيد اكبر ياتي بعد عقود من القمع
الوحشي من قبل نظام قاسم بريطانيا تقف الى
جانب الشعب الايراني الشجاع الذي يطالب
بحقوقه وحريته هذه الشجاعه تظهر من خلال
الواقع المؤلم بان اكثر من 500 شخص قتلوا
18 الف اخرين اعتقلوا خلال الموجه الاخيره
من الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
اصوات المعتقلين الاجانب في ايران بدات
تطلب النجده اياما بعد اعدام النظام
الايراني للبريطاني رضا اكبر بتهمه التجسس
متهم اخر بالتجسس بدا يحاول نفذ بجده
ومغادره السجون الايرانيه والحديث هنا عن
الامريكي سياميك نازيك الاخير اعلن بدا
اضراب عن الطعام للفت انتباه الرئيس
الامريكي
للتحرك للافراج عنه وقال سيامكنا مازي في
رساله مفتوحه ان جل ما يطلبه من الرئيس هو
تكريس دقيقه من وقته في الايام المقبله
لماثر رهائن الامريكيين في ايران
[موسيقى]
وهي في اعلان ماضي عن الاضراب عن الطعام
في ذكرى الافراج عن خمسه امريكيين في
العام 2016 وكان ذلك في اطار البرنامج
النووي الايراني الذي تم تعليقه في من بعد
ويبقى ملف الرهائن الامريكيين والاجانب
بشكل من بين او يشكل من بين الملفات
الخارجيه الهامه المطروحه على طاوله
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه وهو ما كان دفعه
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه الى الاعلاني
قبل اسابيع لبذل مجهودات للتواصل الى حل
للافراج عن المواطنين الامريكيين
المعتقلين في ايران
سجن ايفين الذي يقضي فيه نماذي عقوبته يضم
ايضا العديد من السجناء الاجانب التي تم
توجيه تهم مختلفات اليهم من بينهم عماد
شرقي وهو رجل اعمال ايراني امريكي ومحكوم
عليه بالسجن 10 سنوات بتهمه التخابر هناك
ايضا مراد طهباز وهو ناشط بيئي ايراني
امريكي الجنسيه ايضا ويحمل الجنسيه
البريطانيه كذلك وحكم عليه بالسجن 10
سنوات بتهمه التواضع على امن ايران القومي
في سجن ايفين ايضا النشطه الحقوقيه
الالمانيه الايرانيه والتي حكم عليها
بالسجن 10 سنوات بيتها من متعلقه بالامن
القومي كما يقبع في السجن ايضا احمد رضا
جلال وهو طبيب سويدي الايراني حكم عليه
بالاعدام بتهمه التجسس لصالح اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
كشفت قناه العربيه والحدث تفاصيل اجتماع
القاهره الذي جمع اطراف الليبيه حيث طالبه
خليفه حفتر بضروره توحيد المؤسسه العسكريه
وتمت مناقشه دمج عناصر الميليشيات المسلحه
في الجيش بشكل تدريجي فيما اتفق المشاركون
في الاجتماعي على ابعاد المتطرفين وذوي
الاحكام الجنائيه كما اكدوا على ضروره
وجود حكومه موحده وحياديه تقود الانتخابات
وتكون مدعومه شعبيه وليس حكمتين
وطرحت ضمن المشاورات نقطه ضروري وقف العمل
بالاتفاقيات التي ابرمتها الحكومه حكومه
دبي
طرحها لاستفتاء الشعبي فيما بعد كما تمت
مناقشه وقت في اي اتفاقيات ثم ابراها
حاليا لمنع حدوث اذنت في ليبيا
[موسيقى]
اثار قرار المحكمه باذنه زوجه الرئيس
السودانيه المعذول عمر البشير وداد بابكر
بتهمه الثراء المشبوهه اثارت ردود افعال
واسعه في السودان جزء من الشارع السودانيه
اعتبر القرار خطوه لتحقيق العداله في
البلاد وادانه محكمه جرائم الفساد
ومخالفات المال العام ادانت وداد بابا بكر
بغرامه قدمها 100 مليون جنيه ومصادره عدد
من العقارات والاراضي الزراعيه والمشغولات
الذهبيه
حكم على زوجها من قبل بحيازه النقد
الاجنبي واليوم هي المتهمه بتهمه الثراء
الحرامي والمشبوه داخل محكمه جرائم الفساد
ومخالفات المال العام بالخرطوم وبعد ثلاث
سنوات من المداولات على وداد بابكر زوجه
الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير اضف المحكمه
بمصادره عقارات واراضي زراعيه ومشغوله
ذهبيه ورغم ضخامه الغرامه التي تقدر ب 100
مليون جنيه لصالح حكومه السودان الا ان
العقوبه مخففه بنظر قانوني
لم تتم محاكمتها بموجب قانون ازاله تمكين
او قانون يعني التغيير الاجتماعي حصل يعني
بموجب مقتضياته وقوانينه وانما بقانون
لانقاذ ذات نفسه كثير من القانونيين
السودانيين يعتقدوا ان هذا الحكم جاء يعني
مخففا لم ياتي هذا الحكم مشدد الظرف الشده
المفترضه والمتوقع
على الجانب الاخر يرى المدافعون عن وداد
بابكر ان المحكمه شابتها مخالفات وانهم
ماضون في استئناف القرار الان القرار من
المحكمه اليوم صدر كل ممتلكات ابناء على
الرغم منه ابناء برده مواجهه بيتهم وفصل
البلاغ في مواجهتهم او فصول الالتهاب في
مواجهه الممارسه المحليه من يقدم
مواطنون ان الاجراء هو الطريق الصحيح
لاسترداد اموال الدوله المنهوبه عبر
القضاء لارسال العداله
دائما لانه صورتنا
صوره امنيه على ثلاثه اجزاء
حريه سلام عداله
في اموال مهربه
تضعوا المواطن السوداني مراقبه
في تحقيق العداله وخوفين من ضياع حقه لين
يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه في مقابله مع
العربيه رئيس وزراء الباكستان يشيد بدعم
دول الخليج ويؤكد انه ساهم في تقليل
الاعباء الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
القسطره القلبيه العلاجيه
وجراحات القلب
المواساه خبره تنبض بالثقه
[موسيقى]
الحياه عذاب وقت ما تقدر تاخذ نفس عليك
اوتريفن يزيل احتقان الانف ست مرات اسرع
من الحبوب ويساعدك على التنفس بشكل افضل
لغايه 12 ساعه خذ نفس عميق
وشرف قد يحول الصياده الى فريسه
يعني
طير اخذ موجه الريح ويصعد ناحيه الرمال
اللي هي مغريه جدا
صقور وصيددها الى ماساه لاهالي الصحراء
المصريه
الاخير فاضطر ان هو يدفنه تحقيق خاص عن
الظروف الغامضه التي صاحبت موت ثلاثه
افراد من عائله واحده كل دروب وكل عرعر
وصحراء ملهاش كبير السقاره في مصر مهما
خاصه السبت التاسع والنصف على شاشه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
هذه اللحظه اللي يبدا فيها الم يخف واشعر
فيها اني راح انام طول الليل
[موسيقى]
مرحبا من جديد
كانت طبيبه في احدى المنظمات الدوليه وقد
تعطلت عن العمل جراء الفرمان الجديد
لطالبان بمنع السيدات من العمل في
المنظمات الدوليه والمحليه تقول ان راتبها
كان المصدر الوحيد لعائلتها واطفالها
السته
بعد ما اعلن الطالبان انها لا تسمح لنا
بالعمل زوج عاطل عن العمل وضعنا الاقتصادي
ضعيف نعيش حياه صعبه في منزل باجره
بهار هي الاخرى كانت عامله في المجال
الصحي في احدى المنظمات وقد تعطلت عن
العمل ايضا وابوها قد توفي منذ زمن وهي
المعينه الوحيده لعائلتها التي تعيش في
وضع اقتصادي صعب كما تقول
والمنظمات بدورها قامت بتسريح العامله
فيها وبالتالي لم استطع الاستمرار في
العمل يقول عدد من الطبيبات والعاملات في
مجال الصحه ان القيود المختلفه التي
فرضتها طالبان على النساء الافغانيات قد
اضرت بهن كثيرا بحسب الطبيبات والعاملات
في مجال الصحه فان القرار بمنع السيدات من
العمل في المنظمات قد خلق مخاطر قاتله
لملايين النساء والاطفال الذين يحتاجون
الى عمل الطبيبات
العربيه كابول
مشهد غريب ينتشر بواجهات محلات الازياء
بجميع انحاء العاصمه الافغانيه كابول مشهد
ربما يكون مخيفا للبعض فالعرضات في متاجر
الملابس النسائيه رؤوسهن مغطاه باكياس من
القماش او ملفوفه باكياس بلاستيكيه سوداء
وذلك بامر من سلطات طالب العلم
[موسيقى]
وضع النساء في افغانستان لا يزال ويتصدر
العناوين في ظل الاخبار القديمه من هناك
اخر التطورات التي عادت لي تضع اوضاع
المراه الافغانيه تحت المجهر في حادثه
القتل التي ذهب ضحيتها نائبه برلمانيه
سابقه الامر يتعلق بالنائبه السابقه
والتي كانت واحده من عضوات البرلمان
القليلات التي قررنا لقاء في افغانستان
رغم صعود طالبان الى السلطه في اغسطس من
عام 2001
فيما يتعلق بدوافع الهجوم
فت- اا الروايات حسب مصدرها حسب زعمي
قائدي الشرطه تابع لحركه الطالبان مولى في
حميد فان حارسا ثالثا فراى من مكان الحادث
ومعه نقود ومجوهرات ما قد يوحي بان الامر
يتعلق بجريمه جنائيه في المقابل اوضح بعض
انصار المرسالنا بزاده ان السياسيه الشابه
كانت قد تلقى التهديده بالقتل بسبب
حملاتها لدعم حقوق المراه وفي نفس السياق
اكدت عضوه البرلمان السابقه مريم سليمان
خيل عبر تغريده لها ان النبي زاده كانت
بطله لا تعرف الخوف وامراه قويه لم تتخلى
عن مبادئها وبقيه تواجه الاخطار ما قبل
اربعه اشهر ظهرت مرسال على شاشه التلفزيون
المحلي منتقده قيود طالبان على حريات
المراه صيام القرارات الاخيره مثل منع
النساء ولوج الجامعات او منعهن من
الاشتغالي داخل مؤسسات اجنبيه
معنى منا لندن شكريه
باركزاي البرلمانيه السابقه والنشطه
الافغانيه مرحبا بك معنا سيد شكريه في
اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نتحدث ربما الان عن اول عمليه اغتيال
سياسي منذ استيلاء طالبان على السلطه
تصفيه عضوه البرلمان الافغاني السابق
مرسال النبي زاد برايك من يقف وراء عمليه
التصفيه هذه ولاي غايه
كيكيو
تم اغتيارها
وقوع اي حوادث اسري او مساء الاسريه لكنها
بالفعل
عمل عمل
حارس شخصي قتل ايضا
واخيه جرح وهي اختي لك
وامسكيو
لانها كانت تشعر بانها
ليست بماء من
وايضا هناك
كانت توضا يتم اخلاقها من افغانستان وانا
حاورتها في
سبتمبر 2021 لكن للاسف وعمليات الاخلاء
كانت معقده ما زال هناك
همم
يختبئنا في افغانستان في مختلف انحاء
البلاد وبالتالي هناك خشيه كبيره من بين
من بينهن واعتقد
المعسل يا اصحابي
همم
تلقيت رسائل من اكثر من 20 امراه من
النشيطات في افغانستان همم يعبرنا فيها عن
عدم شعورهن بالامان هناك والواقعه كانت
امام
اغتيال برسال كان امام همم وزاره العدل
وايضا افغانستان ليست امنه هناك علامه
استفهام كبيره بل يقوم بمثل هذه الاعمال
البشعه خاصه
القياده شكريه هذه النقطه هامه تفضلت بها
ان تتواصلت مع
عضوه البرلمان السابقه التي اغتيلت مرسال
النبي زاده وذكرت بانها كانت تريد الخروج
من افغانستان
دعيني هنا استغل الفرصه لاسالك عن
السياسات الافغانيات اللواتي شغلنا مناصب
سابقا قبل طالبان على السلطه هل تعتقدين
انه الان بات مستحيلا النظال من داخل
افغانستان مع حكم طالبان
مقاومه
[موسيقى]
مدنيه همم
تقودها النساء الافغانيات رغم صعوبتها
والرغمه
الثمن الذي تدفعه الامراه في افغانستان
وبصراحه افغانستان اصبحت سجن كبير
بس ده يقعد ياكل
فرصه همم غداره لكن هناك من يحاربون داخل
افغانستان همم
شوفوا اللي نعده كان هناك خشيه ايضا من
وقفه خدمات الانترنت وكيف سيتم التواصل
همم
هذا قطع لكن هناك وسائل يتواصلون فيها
ويندمنا عملهم لا يمكن ان نقول لا نستطيع
القول انه لا يوجد مقاومه داخل افغانستان
ولكن الشعب الافغاني لن يقبل
بطالبان قائد لهم همم
اعتقد ان طالبا ان لم يواجه هذه المقاومه
وسيقبلون
بما يحدث الا ان مقاومه الشعب هي التي لحد
انت ما هم يخشونه الانتخابات وان يكون
هناك مقاومه من الشعب ويعبرون عن صوتهم
بالرفض لطالب وهذا هذه مساله لا يقبلها لا
نستطيع ان نقلل من شان مقاومه الشعل
الافغاني رغم كل القسوه والعنف من طالبا
لكنهم لم يقبلوا طالبان قياده لهم او احد
يمكن ان يشكل الحكومه والشعب ليس له مطالب
من طالبان وهذه المرحله فيها خيبه امل
للشعب لا يوجد فرص عمل ولا لا يطالبون من
همم النظام انه يقدم لهم هذه الفرص بل هم
ينتظرون
الطالب
حقيقه يعني على هذا التوصيف الوافي للوضع
في افغانستان لانه ربما سيحتمل همم الكثير
من الوقت لشرح ما يحصل هناك نحن لكن نحن
حاول تسليط الضوء عليه بكل الاشكال شكرا
جزيلا لك على حضورك معنا هذه الليله شكريه
مركز البرلمانيه السابقه والناشطه
الافرانيه كنت معنا الاندر
[موسيقى]
افغانستان الى باكستان وفي مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه قال رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني شهب
شريف ان المصائب الاقتصاديه في بلاده
تضاءلت بسبب دعم دول الخليج لباكستان
واوضح رئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه انه يتم
العمل على تطوير التعاون في مجال التجاره
والاستثمارات مع الدول الخليجيه
باكستانها
الدعم الملموس والقيم جدا من الدول
الشقيقه في الخليج وليس هناك ادنى شك في
ذلك سواء كان من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
او الامارات العربيه المتحده ونوال الاخرى
صدقيني وهذا لا يعني اننا يجب ان نتطلع عن
الحصول على الايباد والهدايا من اشقاء الى
الموفقين
امه لا لديها اندفاع قوي والقدره على
الصمود والشجاعه
شهد شريف اكد ان بلاده تريد العيش بسلام
مع الهند بشرط يحل المشكلات الاساسيه وقال
الرئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه ان باكستان
والهند خبطتها ثلاثه حروف وكانت النتيجه
المزيده من البطاله والفقر
علينا اتخاذ القرار لقد تعلمت باكستان
الدرس لقد خضنا ثلاثه حروب مع الهند
وعواقب تلك الحروب او نتائجها كانت فقط
المزيد من البؤس والبطاله والفقر
والملايين وهبطوا الى مستويات ادنى لقد
تعلمنا الدرس ونود ان نعيش بسلام مع الهند
بشرط حل مشكله الاساسيه وهذه مساله مهمه
جدا يا اختي لذلك فان رساله الى القياده
الهنديه ورئيس الوزراء مودي
لنجلس والله خذ محادثات جده وصادقه لحل
مسائلنا الملحه مثل كشمير التي تشهد
انتهاكات صارخه لحقوق الانسان في كل يوم
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بعد ان اختفى ل
30 عاما ايطاليا تعتقل اخطر زعماء المافيا
والمطلوب رقم واحد
[موسيقى]
اي نوع الم اول شكوى
للحين ما تلاقي اللي يحررك منه
بس هذيك اللحظه اللي بتبدا تشعر فيها انك
اخيرا بتتحرر منا هي نفس اللحظه اللي
بتشعر فيها انك رجعت لطبيعتك زي في اي يوم
طبيعي
[موسيقى]
ايش ما كان نوع المك
التحرر من الالم يبدا بباندول قلم حساسيه
الاسنان مشكله شائعه مره معجون سنسوداين
المطور ترميم حمايه الجديد بيدخل لعمق
السن وهذا بيساعد فانه يقلل من حساسيه
الاسنان امسح الاشخاص انهم ما يهملوا
مشكله حساسيه الاسنان
[موسيقى]
العربيه
صوت يتردد وحلم يتحقق مع مركز الاخصاب
وعلاج العقم بقدراته الاستثنائيه المركز
تخصصي الطبي رمز الثقه في الرعايه الصحيه
[موسيقى]
المناعه القويه تبدا بعدد صحيه
مع فيتامين سي وزنك وفيتامين دال يساعد
على تعزيز مناعتك يوم بعد يوم خلي سنترم
جزء من روتينك اليومي
[موسيقى]
قوات الدرك في ايطاليا اعتقال الهارب واحد
اخطر زعماء المافيا انه ماتيو مسينا
دينارو وذلك بعد 30 عاما من الفرار حيث تم
القبض عليه وهو يخضع لعلاج في عياده خاصه
بجزيره صقليه تحت اسم المستعار
[موسيقى]
وحده خاصه من قوات الدرك الايطالي
الكرفينياري القات القبض على هذا الستيني
نحيل البنيان في مدينه باليرمو بجزيره
صقليه ناقل المافيا الاشهر
زعيم
الملقب بديابوليك او الشيطاني اختبا من
العداله منذ 30 عاما بعد ارتكابه سلسله من
الجرائم التي اوصلته لتصدر لائحه اكثر
المطلوبين للعداله الايطاليه
وضمن اكثر عشره مجرمين خطوره في العالم
رئيسه الوزراء جورج جميل انتقلت شخصيا
لجزيره صقليه لتشكر مسؤولي القضاء والشرطه
على هذا الانجاز الذي وصفته بانتصار
للدوله
نسينا دينارو ابتدا مسيرته الاجراميه في
مطلع الثمانينات من القرن الماضي كاتل
ماجور بسيط الى عام
1993 حيث شارك في التخطيط وتنفيذ سلسله من
التفجيرات التي استهدفت قضاه وسياسيين
ايطاليين واودت بحياه العشرات
وكان الهدف منها هو ارهاب الحكومه
الايطاليه لتطلق سراحه زعيم المافيا انا
ذاك سلفادور ريرينا وعددا من معاونه فشلت
حمله التفجيرات في ارغام الحكومه
الايطاليه على اطلاق سراح رجال المافيا
المسجونين فاختفى مسينا دينارو
لثلاثه عقود الى ان القي عليه القبض في
مستشفى في ثقل المياه العربيه
مشاهدينا لدينا تطور الان يحدث في هذه
اللحظات من ساندييغو في كاليفورنيا التي
تتعرض لمنخفض جوي منذ ايام صور للفيضانات
اذن من هناك التي غمرت الشوارع في ولايه
كاليفورنيا الامريكيه الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن كان اعلن الولايه بانها منطقه كارثه
كبرى همم بسبب هذه الامطار الغزيره التي
تهاطلت همم في الايام الماضيه همم طبعا
همم الفيضانات والعواصف ادت همم الى مقتل
19 شخص همم حتى همم ما ادى الى اعلانها
منطقه كارثه كبرى من قبل الرئيس الامريكي
تذاكر في امريكا الاسبوع الخامس على
التوالي وحقيقه تجاوزت 38 مليون دولار
خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع وبذلك يرتفع
اجماليه الاراده المحليه للفيل مع المنتج
من ديزني
الى 570 مليون دولار اضافه الى ايرادات
على مستوى العالمي بلغت ما يقرب من مليار
ونصف الملياردولار
[موسيقى]
رفضت قناه العربيه الموجه الثالثه لتساقط
الثلوج على جبل اللوز شمال غرب السعوديه
والذي يتبع لمنطقه نيوم جبل اللوز يرتفع
لمسافه اكثر من 2500 متر فوق مستوى سطح
البحر
هذه هي اللحظات الاولى لتساقط الثلوج
اماتي جبل اللوز في منطقه نيوم في درجه
حراره تصل الى صفر مئويه
وتعتبر هذه الموجه او تساقط الثلوج هي
الموجه الثالثه التي تشهدها القمه خلال
هذا العام
اخبار الساعه تنتهي الان تذكير بابرزها
في اوكرانيا بعد المسيرات حرب دبابات كيف
تنتقل من الدفاع الى الهجوم وتطلب مدرعات
من برج ايفال رساله تضامن الفرنسيه مع
المحتجين في ايران وامريكيون مسجون في
طهران يبدا اضرابا عن الطعام
جريمه غامضه في كابول وروايهتان ناشطتنا
افغانيه تقتل واتهامات لطالبات بالوقوف
وراء الحادثه
[موسيقى]
بعد ان اختفى ل 30 عاما ايطاليا تعتقل
اخطر زعماء المافيا والمطلوب رقم 1
شكرا لكم على كلام المشاهده المزيد دائما
يبقى العربيه على مواقع التواصل الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]